The following
content is provided
by MIT OpenCourseWare under
a Creative Commons license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
We're ready to go.
So this will be the last lecture
that I give maybe, almost,
and the last one
that we'll videotape,
and then Monday we start
on the presentations.
And we'd better get
rolling on those
because time will
run out on us, and I
want everybody who would
like to to have a chance
to talk about work.
OK.
Can I begin?
So I promised to speak
about inverse problems,
ill-posed problems.
It's a giant
subject, but there's
one thing I didn't do,
one beautiful thing that I
didn't do well at the
end of the last lecture.
And I if you don't mind I'd like
to go back to that, because --
the number one example for
optimization is least squares,
minimizing b minus A*x squared.
Here's b; here
are all the A*x's.
Think of it as a
line, but of course
it could be a
n-dimensional subspace.
And then this is the winner.
And the reason it's the winner
is that it's a right angle,
it's a true projection.
And there's a second
problem, which
is minimize this thing,
the distance to w,
where w lies on this
perpendicular direction.
And, of course,
the closest point w
to the b in this
direction is there.
So those are the actual winners
that get the little stars.
And when we're there, the
length of this squared
plus the length of this squared
equals the length of b squared.
We have right angles,
and Pythagoras,
a squared plus b squared
equals c squared is right.
But then, so what I added just
quickly at the end was the key
point about -- suppose I take
any allowed A*x and any allowed
w.
Then I would expect -- and I
look at that distance which is
larger than this, and I look at
this distance which is larger
than this, so of course -- now
I'm not looking at the optimal
ones but instead looking
at these solid line ones,
and then the b minus A*x squared
is bigger than it has to be.
The b minus w squared
is bigger, so the sum
is b squared plus another term.
So that's weak duality,
that for any choice,
some inequality holds, since
this is never negative --
another way to say weak duality
would be to say that this is
always greater or equal to.
But what I didn't
throw in last time
was: there's this
beautiful expression
for what the difference is.
If you don't have the optimum,
this is what you miss by.
And one part of the beauty is
that that tells us right away
how to recognize the optimum.
Duality holds, equality holds
without this term when this
term is 0, when b is
equal to A*x plus w,
and of course that's the good
dashed line case when that
vector plus that
vector is exactly b.
A*x and the w make b.
Those are the dashed
lines; that's optimal.
So somehow the optimality
condition is this one,
and this is a condition that
connects the two problems.
See, here we had a minimization
of this. w didn't appear.
In the dual problem we had
a minimization of this.
x didn't appear.
But when we get both problems
right then they connect.
And this is the step that
in my three-step framework
for applied math that dominated
18.085, there was the x,
there was the b minus Ax,
there was the shift over to w.
So a matrix A entered there, a
matrix A transpose entered here
to give A transpose w equals
0, and here is the bridge.
That's the bridge between them
which in this simple model
problem is -- I usually write
that bridge with a physical
constant c, and in this
simple model problem c was 1,
or c was the identity.
So then this equals this, which
is our optimality condition.
So when we have that
bridge between one problem
and the dual problem
we've got them both right.
So I'm happy to find that.
But I have a problem for you.
You may say, where did
that identity come from?
So that's simply an identity.
And it came from just
multiplying it out.
If I multiply out, take b minus
A*x transposed times b minus
A*x.
Take this transposed
times itself.
b transposed b This
transpose this.
It works.
The terms cancel, and
this is an identity.
Now that's a simple
identity in geometry,
so my puzzle for
you is take this --
let me draw the identity here.
So here's my picture.
I'm going up to any w.
And here is b in this picture.
So b minus w is there.
This says that
some vector squared
plus that squared equals that
squared plus that squared.
So now I just have to
find all those vectors
and ask you prove it.
So let me name
all these vectors.
So here is b minus A*x.
Right?
That's b minus A*x.
And here's w.
OK.
Let me get them all right.
I have to get b in there
and here is b minus w,
and here's b minus A*x.
And what's the fourth one?
The fourth one is
this mysterious one.
So I go up b minus A*x, w.
I'll have to put that here.
I'm going up this
same w, straight up.
There is the
mysterious fourth guy:
b minus A*x minus w is there,
and this was the b minus A*x.
And this identity holds.
It's gotta be, like,
Pythagoras could
have figured it out, but how?
Let me draw this very
same picture again.
So it's this line, this line,
this line, and this line.
And let me just call
those a, b, c, and d.
And they connect.
Oh sorry, there's a
rather important fact.
So this statement here
then says that a squared --
no what does it say?
a squared plus c squared,
maybe, is the first two,
and this one is b
squared plus d squared.
And why?
Please submit a proof
to get an A. OK.
Let me get the picture right.
So this is just
dotted lines here.
So that's a rectangle,
and there is d.
So I have four lines
starting at the same point.
Two of the lines go to the
corners of a rectangle.
So it's a geometry problem,
which struck me early this
morning -- too
early this morning.
But it must be, of course, it
can't be news to the world.
But I think I've got it right:
a squared plus c squared
equals b squared plus d squared.
We take any point and
connect to the four corners
of a rectangle, and that holds.
And the question is why?
It holds from
algebra, but somehow
we also ought to be able to
get it out of Pythagoras.
So as far as I know none of
these angles are special.
That might look equal to that
or something, but it's not,
I don't think.
You know, that point is off --
this d point, it's anywhere.
It's off center, and
here's the rectangle
that it's connecting
to the corners of.
So there you go.
Open problem.
Why is that true?
And I'm sure it is, so this
isn't a wild goose chase,
but I'm just wondering what
proofs can we find for that.
OK.
Can I leave you with that?
I'll leave that on
the board and hope
you'll listen to my presentation
about ill-posed problems,
but I hope you copied
that little picture
and will either email me
or hard copy, or whatever.
Anyway let me know a
good way to prove it.
OK.
Now the lecture begins.
Today's lecture begins.
Oh, I had one other comment
about the interior point method
with the barrier problem.
I got down, at the
end, to an equation --
you remember I was
taking the derivative,
solving the barrier problem,
which was minimizing c*x minus
some multiple of
the barrier log x_i.
So I took the derivative of
this quantity and set it to 0.
And the derivative in
respect to x gave me
the equation c
equals alpha over x.
Anyway, I kind of lost my
nerve, but all I want to say
is this is right and it
leads to Newton's method
that we spoke about.
I won't go back to that.
All right.
Inverse problems.
I think maybe the
best thing I can
do in one lecture
about inverse problems
is, first of all, to get
a general picture of what
are they.
Secondly, to mention areas that
we will all know about, where
these inverse problems enter.
And then thirdly,
to look a little bit
at the integral
equations that often
describe inverse problems.
Inverse problems come from
many sources, not only
integral equations,
but integral equations
are responsible for quite a few.
But let's think about others.
OK, so really, I plan now
to list various examples.
And number one
I've already spoken
about: find velocities
from positions.
Take the derivative.
So taking the derivative is
a process that makes things
bigger, so when we go
the other way we're --
so the difficulty with the
problem is that a small change
in the position data may
be a very large change
in the velocity.
For example,
suppose the position
is the correct
position, say x of t,
plus some noise
term that's going
to be small, small in
size, small in amplitude,
but not small in derivative.
Maybe like sine
of t over epsilon.
So that would be a case in
which a small noise term
in the position -- so
this is the position --
has a big effect
on the derivative.
And that's why the
problem is ill posed.
The problem is ill posed -- and
it goes with our intuition that
high frequency -- this 1 over
epsilon down below is producing
a high frequency
oscillation here.
And of course,
everybody realizes
the velocity is
the correct, dx/dt,
plus the derivative of
this, which brings out a 1
over epsilon, maybe
it's a cosine.
Maybe it's a cosine.
So the 1 over epsilon
cancels the epsilon; that's
a cosine of t over epsilon.
So this was small.
A small change in position
produced an order of 1 change
in the velocity.
So if we only know
position within epsilon,
we're in trouble.
And this is exactly the
point of ill-posed problems.
Then our velocity could be that.
I could make this example worse
if I increase the frequency
further -- put an
epsilon squared there.
Then the amplitude
would still be small,
but when I take the derivative,
there'd be a 1 over epsilon,
the amplitude would
actually be very large.
So I was just modest to keep
epsilon and epsilon there,
so that they canceled
each other and produced
an effect on the derivative.
So that's the problem.
If you have noisy
data about position,
how can you get velocity?
OK, so that's like
example number one.
It's very important,
and I actually, I
have no magic recipe for it.
But let me mention other
problems that you'll know about
like, well, seismology.
A typical inverse
problem in seismology
would be find the densities,
find earth density,
say from travel times of waves,
from wave travel time, which
is what we can measure.
So that's seismology
and also, of course,
everybody understands
that this is what
oil exploration depends on.
You set off an explosion on
the surface of the earth,
the wave travels into the
earth and some part of it
bounces back, and in
fact, maybe several pieces
bounce back at different times.
And from those results you
have to sort of back project
to find the density.
So back projection
is a word that
comes into several of
these applications.
Of course, another one would
be the medical ones: CT scans,
MRI, PET -- all these
ways to take measurements.
And from those measurements
you have to find the density,
so you're looking
for density of tissue
because you hope that would
allow you to distinguish
a tumor from normal tissue.
So that's a giant
area of applications.
Oh, another one would be find
the density of the earth --
let's say another way to find
the density of the earth,
another bit of
information we have --
from the gravitational field.
You see, that's
what we can measure:
the effect of gravity, the
effect of the earth's density.
We measure the effect, and
we want to know the cause.
That's the problem.
And this reminds me that there
is a special lecture coming
by Professor Wunsch, Carl Wunsch
at MIT -- he's outstanding --
and that's Wednesday,
May 10 at 4 o'clock.
And in fact, his abstract,
which you might see somewhere --
I can post it on the course
website -- his abstract tells,
he's solving a very,
very large-scale,
ill-posed optimization problem.
Least squares problem.
Perfect for this course.
So those are familiar.
The books I've been
looking at just
list whole lots of examples.
Let me see.
Oh, scattering.
Let me just keep going here.
This is number five.
Scattering.
From scattering
data, find the shape
of the obstacle that's
responsible for the scattering.
So that's a giant example with
many air force applications
and many other applications.
But we recognize, if
you want to identify
some object by scattering, by
radar data and other scattering
data.
Well, there are
just lots of others.
Oh, and then the general
question of: we have a Laplace
or a Poisson equation,
which is the divergence
of some inhomogeneous material
property equals some f of x, y.
OK, so what we're usually
doing, in this course and most
courses, is the direct
problem of find u,
so the direct problem is find u.
And what's the inverse problem?
The inverse problem is we know
u and f and we have to find c.
So find the coefficient.
Well, how much information --
it may not be instantly clear
whether it's possible.
In fact, it probably
is not possible,
and that's what makes
the problem ill posed.
Yet if you have
enough measurements
of inputs and outputs, you
could reconstruct the matrix.
Of course, a person like me is
going to think about the matrix
question.
Suppose I'm looking
for the matrix A.
Can I call this number seven?
And since it's in
matrix notation,
it doesn't take much space.
Usually I know the matrix,
and I know b and I want x.
In the inverse
problem I know b and x
and I want to know the matrix.
What was the matrix
that produced it.
Well obviously one
pair b, x is not
going to be enough to produce
the matrix, but enough will.
But then if there's noise --
this is the point, of course,
that there's always noise.
So that's what I now
have to deal with.
The main thing is how to deal
with noise in the data, noise
in the measurements, because
if the problem is ill posed,
we saw even in that
simple cooked up example
that a small amount of noise
could produce a big difference
in the solution.
OK.
Right.
So those are examples.
Now I wanted -- because math
courses and this one never
mention integral equations,
I thought I would write one
on the board.
And these examples
fit in this --
if I describe them
mathematically or another whole
list of problems that I'm
seeing in the books on ill-posed
problems -- very often they are
integral equations of the first
kind.
Again, the direct problem is
-- I'd better write it down --
the direct problem
-- this is known.
So the direct problem
is given the K, which
is a bit like c over here,
find the u, solve for u.
Solve for the unknown u.
It's a linear problem.
It's an A*x equals b problem,
only it's in function space.
And of course, one way
to solve it will be,
probably the way to
solve it numerically
will be somehow
make it discrete,
bring it down to
a matrix problem.
That's what we
would eventually do.
But in function space,
integral equations
played a very, very
important historical role
in the development
of function spaces.
And now, then the
inverse problem would
be given u find the x, I guess.
Something like that.
That would be possible.
That would be one possible:
inverse number one.
But I wanted to make some
comments on integral equations,
just so you would
have seen them.
The integral could go up to
x or it could go up to what?
And Volterra and Fredholm are
the names associated with those
two possibilities,
but these are both --
whether Volterra or Fredholm
-- they're both ill posed,
whereas if I want to make
them well posed -- well,
we've seen how to make
a problem well posed.
I have this operator A,
which has a terrible inverse
or no inverse at
all, and the way
I improve it is add a little
multiple of the identity.
I'm supposing that I know about
A, that it's not negative,
that its eigenvalues can be
very, very small or 0 but not
negative.
So when I add a little bit,
it pushes the eigenvalues away
from 0 up at least
as far as alpha.
And over here, if I add in alpha
u of x, that's what it does,
of course.
I've added alpha times
the identity operator here
and that's given me an
equation of the second kind.
So those three minutes were just
to say something about language
and to look at an integral
equation, something
we don't do enough of.
Integral equations -- well,
some problems on nice domains,
you can turn differential
equations into integral
equations, and it pays
off big time to do that.
Professor White in EE, if he
taught a course like this,
it would end up with
half a dozen lectures
on integral equations
because he's
an expert in converting
the differential equation
to an integral equation.
He would convert
Laplace's equation
to an integral equation, and
the Green's function would enter
and he would solve it there.
OK, so how does velocity fit?
Well, everybody can see that
the integral of velocity --
so example, the velocity example
is that the integral from 0
to x of the velocity, that's
of course integral from 0 to x
of -- or 0 to t maybe
would be a better --
so suppose velocity
is d position, dx/ds.
So it's x of t minus x of 0.
So this is position.
This is velocity.
And in the inverse problem,
position is known, say by GPS,
and velocity is
unknown, to find by GPS.
So GPS will give you a
measurement of position.
Maybe you know
something about GPS.
You know that there
are satellites
up there whose position
is known very exactly,
and they have a very very
accurate atomic clock on them,
so that times are
accurately known.
So they send signals down to
your little hundred dollar
receiver, which of course
has a ten-dollar clock in it.
So there'll be some errors,
partly due to the clock,
largely due to the
cheap time keeper.
But actually the way you
get real accuracy out of GPS
is to have two
receivers, and then you
can cancel the clock errors and
get less than a meter accuracy.
If you take account of
all the sources of error,
you can get it down
to centimeters.
So GPS is giving you -- just
your single receiver is still
good enough.
It's measuring the travel
time and since the signals
are coming with
the speed of light,
that tells us the distance
from each satellite.
Right?
Here is your receiver R. Here
is satellite number one, two,
three, four up in the sky,
and you know these distances.
But you don't know
the time very well.
So with four satellites,
I'm able to find
the position of the
receiver is somewhere
in space and some moment of
time that this clock is not
good enough to tell us.
So we have to solve for that.
So four receivers sending
signals to -- I'm sorry,
four satellites sending
signals to the receiver,
we can solve that problem and
find the position and time.
That's the fundamental
idea of GPS.
Now of course, you
get better results
if there's a fifth receiver, a
fifth satellite, and a sixth.
The more the better.
And of course then it's
going to be least squares.
Because you're still
looking for four unknowns,
but now you have six
distances, pseudo-ranges,
so we would use least
squares, so by least squares.
OK.
But what about velocity?
Suppose your receiver is
moving, as of course it
is if you rent a car
that has GPS installed
to tell you where to turn.
And of course, it
has to have a map
system installed so that it can
look up for the map position.
So for many purposes
you need velocity,
and I'm not an expert
on that subject at all.
I just comment that one way
to get velocity is to take
differences, so the velocity is
approximately x of t plus delta
t minus x -- or x
of t_2, let's say,
x of t_2 minus x of
t_1 over t_2 minus t_1.
But if we want to get
velocity near a certain time,
then these t's better
be near that time,
because the velocity's
changing, so we better
be measuring it at the
time we're wanting it.
And then, if they're very close,
then we're dividing by a small
number and the
difference -- the noise,
the error in measurements x, is
multiplied by that 1 over delta
t.
And one way to avoid it is to
go into the frequency domain.
So this is like an
interesting option
in a lot of these problems.
Can you operate better
in the frequency domain?
Of course, the ill-posedness
is not going to go away.
It comes as we saw
from high frequency.
But if we go into
the frequency domain,
and if these GPS satellites are
sending at a certain frequency
and as we move, of course --
the Doppler effect, of course,
is the fact that as
the receiver moves,
the frequency it
observes change a little.
Right?
Just says, like, the
noise of a train going by
is the familiar example.
Nobody ever sees a
train going by anymore.
But it's the same idea.
But you hear traffic go by.
Actually, I guess that that's
how we cross the street, come
to think of it, by listening
to the noise of cars,
and our global
internal Doppler says
the cars are going away from us,
in which case we don't worry,
or it says the car's
coming fast, in which case
we're careful, or it says
the car's coming slowly,
and we get across first.
So we use Doppler.
I don't know exactly how, how
our human audio system builds
in Doppler.
Anyway, Doppler would be
a change to the frequency
domain and a restatement
and perhaps an improvement
in the problem.
OK, so those are
examples without math.
Now here's a small bit of
math as the lecture ends.
So the only math was
this simple example.
So I guess I got one
more board over here.
I'm going to put this geometry
problem that you've been
thinking about out of sight.
OK, so what's the key?
It's this Tikhonov.
Tikhonov Regularization.
And it's adding alpha.
Add alpha to the
least squares problem.
And I thought it was
amusing to notice,
Tikhonov was born in 1906, so
this is a hundred years exactly
since he proposed this method.
It's one of about five methods
that the books describe.
And it's the one I'll speak
about here at the end.
I'll just mention that one
which might come up in a project
possibly.
Other methods are used
in iterative methods,
like conjugate gradients,
and stop when you're ahead.
See if you push conjugate
gradients on and on and on,
then eventually it's
going to produce
your exact ill-posed
matrix with the big inverse
and unrealistic solution.
So you stop.
The same way for an
integral equation.
We discretize that so we
get a matrix product, which
we can solve.
But if we refine the mesh so
that the matrix gets bigger,
it gets more ill posed.
So the closer we get, the
closer the discrete problem
gets to the true integral
equation, the more sick it is.
So there's some point
at which you are OK,
and then if you go too
far, you're worse off.
So that happens with
conjugate gradients.
Now what's the Tikhonov idea?
So the Tikhonov idea is: look
at them -- as you all know --
it's the minimum -- I'll
just call it A again --
A*x minus b squared
plus alpha x squared.
That would be the
simplest penalty
term, regularization term.
So this leads to
the normal equation:
A transpose A plus alpha*I, u
hat, which depends on alpha,
equals b.
OK.
So u_alpha is the
solution to that.
OK, now let's let noise come in.
So noise in b.
Noise yields a b_delta, say
a delta amount of noise.
A b_delta is the
measured observation.
See, we don't know the exact b.
This is what we measured.
And we can suppose that the size
of the noise is -- let's say --
delta.
So delta measures the noise.
OK.
I mean what's my question here?
Always the question is:
what do you take for alpha?
What should that parameter be?
If you take alpha
very small or 0,
then your problem is ill
posed, and the answer you get
is destroyed by the noise.
If you take alpha very large,
then you're overriding the real
problem -- you're
over-regularizing it.
You're over-smoothing it.
So we don't want to
take alpha too large,
but we can't take
alpha too small either.
And the theory will say
that if we use an alpha --
so the theory will say
this, essentially this.
It'll say that the u hat alpha,
the difference between u hat
alpha and u hat alpha with
the noise, coming from the --
do you see what I mean by it?
This comes from the true
b, which we don't know,
but it's the answer
we would like to know.
This comes from the
measured b with noise in it,
and it turns out that
this is of size delta
over square root of alpha.
That's a rather neat
result. It gives us a guide
because we want
that to be small.
So we're assuming that we
have some idea about delta,
and it tells us, again, that
if I take alpha very small,
then I'm not learning anything.
So you see, actually,
that we want,
we need, delta over square
root of alpha to go to 0.
Maybe we're reducing the noise.
Maybe we have a
sequence of measurements
that get better and better.
So delta goes to 0.
We would like to get to
the right answer then,
but as delta goes
to 0, we better not
let alpha go to 0 faster.
The message here is -- so I
haven't derived this estimate
but just written a conclusion,
which is that as the noise goes
to 0 -- that means our
measurements are getting better
and better -- we do want
to let alpha go to 0,
but we can't overdo it.
And a good choice,
a good choice is:
let alpha be delta to the 2/3.
That turns out, from
these little estimates,
to be the best choice, because
then square root of alpha
is delta to the 1/3.
This then is delta divided
by delta to the 1/3.
This is delta to the 2/3,
and we can't do better.
So that's the balancing.
That's the balance when you
take that value of alpha.
Then, as you reduce
the noise, the error
gets reduced in the
same proportion.
It's not the full
reduction in delta,
but the fraction, the 2/3 power.
OK, so that board
summarizes, you
could say, the theory
of regularization.
And there's a lot more
to say about that theory,
but I think this is perhaps
the right point to stop.
OK so that's applications.
One other application, if
I can add one last one,
because it's quite important and
it comes up in life sciences.
So in life sciences
you might have --
in genomics you might have
a lot of genes acting.
So the action of n
genes, n being large,
produces some expression,
the expression of the gene,
and it depends on how much
of those genes are present.
But what everybody wants to know
is which genes are important,
which genes control the blue or
brown eyes, or male or female.
Not clear, right?
We have an idea from
biological experiments
where the important genes
lie on the whole genome,
where to find them
in the chromosome,
but this is what we measure.
We observe male or female,
and we can change the genes,
but we can't get --
there are a lot of genes,
and there are more
unknowns than,
more dimensions
than sample points.
We're really up against it here.
And we're really up
against it because --
so what's going to measure
the importance of a gene?
How important is
gene number two?
Well, the importance
of gene number two
is identified by the
size of the derivative.
That quantity, if
it's big, tells me
that the expression depends
strongly on gene number two.
If it's small, it says gene
number two can be ignored.
That's exactly what
the Whitehead and Broad
Institutes want to know.
Well, for cancer,
of course, as well.
And my only point
here in this lecture
is to say that
again, we're trying
to estimate a derivative.
We're estimating a
derivative from few samples
in high dimension, and
it's certainly ill posed.
And it certainly has
to be regularized,
and it certainly has to
be studied and solved.
So that's maybe a
seventh example,
and with that, I'll
stop the final lecture
and just bring
down one last time
this little bit of
geometry to give you
something interesting
to do for the weekend.
OK, so I'll see you
Monday then, with a talk
about different methods for
solving linear equations
and others coming.
And time is, you know, this
semester will run out on us.
So please send me
emails to volunteer.
And don't think you
have to be perfect.
If you've got transparencies,
got the topic in mind,
got the question in mind,
got some numerical results,
you're ready.
OK.
Good.
Have a good weekend.
Bye.